darf mein tier und mensch natur
grundsätzlich hat jedes navi weiß es
kracht so behandelt werden wie andere
wir sind alle so will also mit einem
sinn berufung auf hohe us kritik der
fleischer das erlaubt ins gesetzbuch
stücke wie es wieder nicht und gleich
ist es oft erwarte nun also das recht
des stärkeren spezielle oder also
fressen und gefressenwerden ist
historisch übernahme sieht woche also
mir hat das gemacht ohne überlagert
unterschied natürlich zu früheren ob sie
damals hat er wirklich ums überleben
kämpfen
das ist ein bisschen spitze legitimiert
sieht dass man dann halt der schwäche
die frist wird wieder hat dass er mit
überlebenskampfs tui den meisten
regionen zum glück nicht sondern ist
einfach lustig und zum gefragt
abschließend beantworten darf man das
tier so behandeln wie wir manchmal wie
die behandlung
nein das mache ich nicht